[موسيقى]
اضحك اضحك سلطان اضحك يضحك سلطانه ومبتسم
بحيره جميله جدا تفضلي يا سلطان احنا
قاعدين
صباح الخير عليك عادل على كافه مشاهدي
صباح العربيه بصراحه اول زياره لي منطقه
الجوف بصراحه يعني شفت مناظر جميله وتنوع
جغرافي عجيب وكبير جدا تخيل في منطقه
واحده بنشوف الكثبان الرمليه بنشوف
اللوحات الزراعيه وبنشوف كذلك كل يوم
بحيره نتحدث عن اكبر بحيره في الشرق
الاوسط نتحدث على محيط هذه البحيره يعادل
يصل ثمانيه كيلو مترات بعمق عشرين متر
نتحدث انه اقرب ساحل بحري لهذه البحيره
يبعد 700 او قرابه 700 كيلو تخيل انت معي
اليوم في وسط الكثبان الرمليه في قلب
الصحراء بنشوف بحيره بهذا الحجم وبهذا
العمق طبعا شكلت هذه البحيره يا عادل عبر
المياه الجوفيه الخاصه بالمزارع اليوم
منطقه الجوف منطقه غنيه بالمياه العذبه
والفائض من هذه المياه الخاصه بالزراعه
ولري بيتوجه عبر انابيب وقنوات مائيه الى
هذه البح اليوم هذه البحيره طورتها الجهات
المعنيه واصبح فيها مرسى واصبح فيها مطاعم
ومقاهي في الجهه المقابله واصبحت وجهه
سياحيه جميله ولطيفه لكل اهالي الجوف وحتى
الكافه السياحه اليوم يستطيع السائح زياره
منطقه الجوف وتحديد الجومه الجندل ممكن
اربع خمسه مواقع سياحيه في مربع واحد وفي
مساحه واحده يقدر يزور اليوم البحيره وبعد
كذا يطلع على قلعه مارد الاثريه وعدد كبير
من المزارات السياحيه في منطقه الغنيه
التي تشهد تطوير مستمر هذه البحيره يعني
السلطان لازم اسالك هل هل نقدر نكشه في
هذه البحيره في اماكن مخصصه نقدر نخيم
مخيم صغير يعني طبعا اليوم السوا
طبعا طبعا سواحل الشاطئه او سواحل البحيره
هذه مهيئه بشكل كبير بالمظلات والشمسيات
والجلسات يستطيعوا الاهالي والسياحه
الاستمتاع باشعه الشمس وقضاء اوقات يعني
مختلفه ولطيفه برفقه عائلاتهم كذلك
المساحات الزراعيه الخضراء المقابله
للبحيره ايضا في متعلق بتوفير دورات
المياه والبنيه التحتيه والمطاعم اليوم في
فصل الصيف تحديدا في الويكند تحديدا من
ساعات الصباح الاولى الى الساعات المتاخره
يا عادل وراويه بتشوف الناس بيستمتعون
بالمنطقه انه تعرف هي منطقه صحراويه في
قلب الصحراء الجوف ولما يكون في متنفس
بحري او مائي بالطريقه هذه يحرص كثير
الاهالي على زيارته زي ما قلنا احنا اقرب
ساحل بحري للمنطقه هذه يبعد قرابه 700
كيلو متر يعني مسافه بعيده جدا لذلك نشاهد
الاهالي يحرسون بشكل كبير على زياره هذه
المنطقه والاستمتاع فيها اليوم الكورنيش
كبير جدا احنا اخذنا زاويه معينه لكن
الكورنيش مساحه كبيره جدا وبمختلف وحتى
معمول بشكل مدرجات وشواطئ رمليه ويستطيع
حتى الاهالي ركوب الخيل واستمتاع
بالجيتسكي وغيرها من المناظر والفعاليات
البحريه وحتى في المنطقه في مهرجانات
سابقه في المنطقه كانت للرياضات البحريه
والسباقات والله اذا ما جينا بالصيف نجيلك
بالشتاء انا احب الشتوي استمتع استمتع
بهذه البحيره الجميله يا سلطان شكرا جزيلا
لك مراسل العربيه سلطان
بين الزيت والزيتونه يلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات